[Music]
there have been some pretty little liars
spin-offs is there any chance you'll pop
up at some point
oh I don't know I know that the girls
have been working really hard at my
girls I mean like Marlene and and and
Sasha and Janelle and they have a whole
new wonderful group of people working on
the fourth action yes and I don't know I
never know anything about I know that
they've already told me which I would be
delighted to do they're like you should
come direct an episode and I was like
that would be someone else and awesome
but but as far as you know if Ally and
and Mona are showing up in this world I
have no idea who else would show up but
I have no idea I can't share I love that
and what is your like dream for your
next thing like thinking a movie another
series like what do you um it's really
open right now I I got to work on a
fantastic movie last year yeah and I
felt very lucky to do that and it just
kind of felt like I've I wanted to
pursue more whatever it was whether it
was a television series or a film or
writing as we were talking about
your own work when does your movie come
out October I don't know if I probably
November there's so many things we don't
know are we going to the wrong wedding
we don't know is your movie coming out
we don't know we have a fascinating is
Megan Marvel getting a Vitamix from
Patrick that you know whether I'm there
or not the Vitamix he's going to the way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]